all right let's get this
going
and we're
live welcome to the weekly poll as usual
I'm Benny the comic storan that is sh
from TV little house that is Rob from
Marvel explained and that is Scott nice
Wander from nerd syn Productions shocker
huh and today's big release that we're
going to tell you about I don't have
anything I'm just going to say Aquaman's
cool it's just cool is the I don't have
I don't have a I don't even know where
they are Aquaman's cool that's all I'm
gonna say agreed turns out
all right so uh welcome to the weekly
pool as usual guys today there has isn't
too much news going on so we're going to
be talking about thorn of atanas we're
going to be talking about uh Secret Wars
and Scott's opinion on the secret War
situation we're going to be talking
about nerding Productions and how great
their channel is and why you should be
visiting there um we should probably
chat about the watch Mojo list that
everyone is talking to us about at this
point um but I don't think we have
anything major so we're just gonna kind
of be us around today we're gonna be
friendly we're we're gonna do in the in
the words of erys from barant give you
all virtual hugs
today virtual hugs I wish I had virtual
hugs to give away but I don't no I a Q&A
I thought that was cool and he gave away
hugs no everyone started bribing
everybody with things and I'm just like
thanks than so um so anyway Scott you
want to give us a rundown on your uh on
your channel yeah sure I'm really
terrible at promoting it so this is just
going to be horrible right now but uh so
nerd sync Productions basically uh we
have a podcast uh that comes out every
Monday but I think the main attraction
is probably comic misconceptions which
is a show where I kind of tackle at
first it was like literal misconceptions
about comic book characters and now it's
more kind of uh a deeper in-depth look
at comics and Comic characters we talk a
lot about the behind the scenes of the
industry and like what writers and
artists were thinking when they created
characters or uh story lines and that
kind of stuff and uh that's kind of what
we're doing right now I think this year
we're trying to promote a lot more
behind the scenes of the comic industry
videos so awesome cool yeah actually I
will say this uh Scott's actually your
channel is one of the ones that I found
when I was doing my research to get into
comicbook channels and stuff like what
what is the current state of the comic
book World i' never even heard of Rob so
I mean you were the guy that I was
looking
at it was you and variant and uh I knew
of salent TV little house but I hadn't I
hadn't watched the entire catalog like I
did eventually it's
fair yep the full catalog of everything
that's going on yeah of everything on
this on the S Channel but no you you've
got some really good stuff there I like
a lot of the stuff you do um and just
because your fans like to do it I'm
going to go ahead and put and say it for
them do a Deadpool video just just do
Deadpool everybody loves Deadpool man
like all like me by and style have done
Deadpool and they're like the highest
rated videos on our Channel sobody loves
going I'm going to do one I've announced
that I'm going to do but I announced
that I was going to do one I think
almost one year ago on like a video
where I was like to everyone asking
about a Deadpool video I'm going to do
it it's I'm working on it it's it's
gonna happen and then I totally just
dropped dropped it off like didn't even
touch it for a year and then finally uh
I finally got a good idea because you
know it's very vague when someone says
do a Deadpool video I'm like what does
that mean right do a Batman one just oh
boy well there's not a lot to talk about
there so I'll try to scrape something
out you know
you I I told you like I think I told you
this before we did your podcast uh which
I did over on your channel uh last week
um but uh uh we discussed that and you
should totally do the voice inside of
Deadpool's head that's what I keep
trying to get somebody else to make a
video
about the voice in Deadpool's head he's
got like three panels in a comic I mean
you can make that work yeah man you
stress that out in like a 15-minute
video right that's true yeah no uh that
was definitely one of the leading
contenders was like trying to diagnose
like what Deadpool's uh mindset is I'm
like uh cuz I did a video about Dr Doom
and like how I proposed a theory that
maybe he has body dysmorphia disorder or
something um you know because I try I
try to go a little bit deeper than than
what's on the surface and I try to come
up with little theories like that and
that was a pretty popular one and so I
tried to think of well what would
Deadpool's diagnosis be and then just
couldn't it's just it's too much stuff I
can't even think no it's funny because
they always give him a different
diagnosis depending on his Origins now
he's crazy now he was already crazy now
we made him crazy now cancer made him
crazy you know this time he has three
voices now he has two voices now there's
four voices that was part of the like
difficulty in getting into or
understanding Deadpool was like his six
different versions of himself and you're
like well apparently he's that's
probably why he's so appealing is
because he appeals to so many different
people he is so many different well
that's that's the problem you can't just
you can't go back you can't just be like
I'm going to pick up like the current
run of Deadpool like you have to go back
and read all these old Deadpool stories
understand what the heck's going on in
Deadpool's mind right but I you need to
go back but I know I like I
like you like I don't know about
that I think you do but it's whatever so
yeah um I mean Scott does a great great
work over at nerd syn guys um it's it's
it's kind of similar to what variant
does but without going into the history
of the characters he explores a lot more
of the outside Concepts and stuff like
that um and he does such a great job of
it that is actually something that
initially I was going to touch on on my
channel but I never did because he does
such a great job over there there's no
reason to he he picks up topics that I
would never even think of like why do
people live in Gotham City I don't know
do they no it's actually funny that you
bring up that one because uh there was
one comment on that video all the other
comments great comments but you know you
always fixate on the one and there was
that one comment of a guy saying like oh
did you run out of ideas this is a
really lame I that that CU because when
I started doing my comic stuff and
everything that and and you know how the
world of a YouTuber is you spend so much
time making product for YouTube that
when you're finally free you don't watch
YouTube you just head out the door and
you go find something else to do that
involves real fresh air because we bre
we breathe computer fumes all day
exactly so it was actually the Gotham
one actually got my attention when
Gotham came out and I was like oh let me
go check out what nerd sing's been up to
and I just go watch the Gotham one so I
mean regardless of that one guy's
comment it was pretty good video in my
opinion yeah like I think my favorite
series on your channel is the comic book
misconceptions that's what we're talking
about Rob you're
yeah I know that I'm saying like that's
like that's that's like the you know
what yeah that's the main attraction I
got fine you know you guys just talk I'm
just gonna here drink my water dude I
had Jimmy John's for lunch too I was
gonna say what company you sponsoring
there
Rob uh I am sponsoring Jimmy John's yeah
who's getting a nickel today crazy crazy
fast crazy something I don't know what
it is I don't know how it is order a
Jimmy John sandwich right now we'll just
see how fast it gets here not saying
that it's a sponsor but
but yeah no what I was trying to say is
Scott does does do a great Channel um
and he's we've actually been talking to
him a while I know you guys have said oh
Scott you should join up on weekly poll
and we've been and I just joined him on
his podcast over there um but it's just
it's more of a scheduling confliction we
never had any problems with Scott it's
just always not seeming to work out so
everyone who is unaware
of everyone who's unaware of nerding
Productions go check out his channel um
I'm pretty sure yours is named nerding
Productions as actual address right like
yeah yes it is okay so yeah so
youtube.com nerdsync Productions or if
you just do YouTube find down in the
description if you feel like refresh in
the Stream y did you really put it in
Midstream no it was in before the before
the stream started but people showed up
here after the stream started or maybe
no I'm sorry before I put it in when the
stream started whatever man it's in
there now just [__] all right so I think
we've done it off of the opening plug
we'll do plenty more plugs under it sync
so let's go ahead and discuss the topic
of the day the movie that came out on
physical copy right now Throne of
Atlantis yep okay now s hasn't seen it
so he's just going to sit quietly in the
corner um I actually saw the movie
before I read the story which was the
funny thing interesting yeah how was
that experience like the movie was was
actually like pretty good I almost
knocked my EIG thing over my um the
movie was actually like movie was decent
enough the problem that I have with the
movie is like I was actually telling the
guys about this before started like
three quarters of the way through like
the movie picks up it's like it's boring
for like three qu that's what I said the
pro the problem with this the issue you
had with it is the movie is not really
about The Throne of Atlantis yeah the
movie is Aquaman's origin and then the
Throne of Atlantis and they were like oh
we've only got 15 minutes left on the
clock well let's have some cool fighting
it sounds like from what you guys were
describing and from what I recall the
book to be uh the the the the mo it's
almost like do you remember when DC
animated made the Wonder Woman
movie actually I didn't watch that one
didn't watch it but I know what you're
talking about I own it and it's really
fun uh I was one of the four people who
bought it and that's why and I think
that DC knows that there is a rabid
Aquaman fan base but they don't quite
know how much that is so they build it
as a Justice League movie but it's
actually just couched it's just an
Aquaman movie that's couched in a
Justice League movie and they're like we
have to have the Justice League in this
freaking movie or people will freak out
so we'll put some Justice League stuff
in there but for the most part it's an
Aquaman flick and that's why it's like I
think it's called Justice League Throne
of Atlantis yeah it is so like you know
I I think that the part of the reason
why it's a little boring is one they're
they're setting up Aquaman they have to
do his origin they have to get him in
the league they have to do that story
and they also have to do this Justice
League story so it's like you're losing
a like it's not really a a coherent
piece right well the problem that I had
with it for the most part um and I I do
like the movie I thought the movie was
great for what it was um I just feel
like I I would have rather them just had
the Aquaman movie and it makes sense
what you're saying there's an Aquaman
fan base and they want the Aquaman fan
base to feel excited and go watch an
Aquaman movie but they're worried about
the rest of the world who still views
Aquaman as your 1970s super friends I
can talk to fish and ride a seahorse
well and the other thing is like it's a
great way to catch all it's a catchall
for all other like superhero fans like I
love the Batman directed DVD movies or
at least I like the Batman character
more than I like say Aquaman and so if
they're going to come up with an Aquaman
movie and I hear no buzz or bad Buzz I'm
just going to skip it but if they call
it justice league I know Batman will be
in it so check it out that makes a lot
of sense yeah and that was the whole
funny thing about it is is like you
watch this movie and like the entire
backdrop like the whole back theme is
okay there's some guy who's living on
the surface like as soon as you see him
you immediately know okay this is
obviously Aquaman the question is how
are they going to go about explaining
how he's there and why he doesn't know
anything about Atlantis doesn't know
what's going on and so as things prog
ress like you have all this Forefront
action which is like this impending
conflict between the atlanteans and the
surface and you know the Wes's name like
the bad guy who looks like a character
from Star Wars looks like Boba Fett I
don't know if it's maybe it's yeah maybe
it's man I don't know the guy who looks
I remember him from Super Friends I
don't know his name is yeah but anyway
but anyway like he's or but all right
he's in like the whole conflict and
everything and um yeah it's like the
whole Forefront issue the only see here
here's one of the things I didn't like
it felt like
it felt like all of a sudden that chick
showed up and she was like you're
Atlantean and he was like okay cool
let's go and like just went down to
Atlanta he just accepted it no questions
asked and it was like I mean that's kind
of how it it's kind of how the story
actually happened because the ACT at
least the most recent origin for Aquaman
is he kind of knew he was a lantean
before he finding out he's a lante
because of Dr Shin and everyone doing
experiments and kind of studying him and
seeing why he's capable of doing what
he's doing so he kind of already had an
idea he was Atlantean so when they
finally do show up to find find him and
he goes looking for Atlantis it's like
okay this is all real let me let me go
look for this by the way I want to do a
quick shout out to comic book Cas they
in our chat oh heyy what's going on
comic book
cast technically it's just Joel but
we'll go ahead and say it's all of
them just I don't know it's it's Joel
that's
cool um but the problem I had with the
with the Throne of Atlantis and uh it's
the the the story itself and the video
from is going to go up my channel either
tomorrow the day after whenever I get
around actually wrapping it up but
you'll and you'll see in the actual
thorn of Atlanta story it's it's about
the people that aren't the Justice
League it's about B team and how B team
has to stand up because the Justice
League has been removed and it's like
Hawkman and like element woman and Green
Arrow and all these people that are
coming forward to basically show that
they're also heroes they're also here to
save the day right you know you don't
have to worry about just the Justice
League and you get this really awesome
like actual war in which it's atlantans
versus the Justice League uh combined
with Justice League B team versus the
trench monsters and then you got volco
with his little thing going oh you know
and it's just like this massive battle
and when it came to the movie it was
just kind of
like we'll just have some cool stuff you
know Flash and Green Green lintern
weren't even in the book so yeah I mean
that right there tells you you know why
I don't like check out stories where
they focus on the B team because the
last time I did that was the death of
Superman when doomsday showed up and
beat the crap out of everybody in
minutes with one hand tied behind his
back oh my God and then pummeled
Superman and I was like okay like I
don't care about B team rosters anymore
yeah know but but wouldn't it wouldn't
it have been cool and and Scott you saw
the movie right and you you said you
read the book a while ago a while ago
okay so you saw the movie then let me
ask you your opinion so if if the movie
had done everything the same but during
the war since the since the Justice
League was trapped in those little like
pod things under the ocean before they
came up and fixed everything we had just
cameos from vixon and Hawkman and green
arrow just oh screw you guys you know
that would been cool yeah yeah it would
have been cool I don't know if I would
still say that I would have it would
have made the movie better but I don't
know if I would say that I would it
would make it a movie that I loved
because I didn't if I'm being honest I
didn't really love this movie at all I
know you have to explain that then
because the odd man out all right I'm
sorry I I love Aquaman ever since the
new 52 he's one of my favorites and so
the the portrayal of him in this movie
as kind of just this mopy guy who
doesn't really I don't know he I didn't
I didn't really like the way that he was
portrayed in this movie I like him more
in the comics he seems more like he's
just this almost guy who gets uh picked
on a lot H and you know he's he's kind
of he almost seems more of like an
introvert he's like trying to keep to
himself and do the best that he can
while everyone else is picking on him in
the comics and in the movie he's just
like some guy who's like I'm gonna just
whine about life to this lobster right
here that's literally what he does like
he's drunk he's sitting in front of a
lobster yeah in and that was another
thing that was another thing that I
didn't like so in the in in the first
issue of uh the new 52 Aquaman he
there's one panel that I've saved and I
use it all the time when people say like
Aquaman all he can do is talk to fish
and it's just one panel of Aquaman's
just looking straight at the lens and
going I don't talk to fish and I love
that and so in the in the movie though
in Throne of Atlantis they there's like
a scene where he just like discovers
that he can talk to fish and he goes oh
so I can talk to fish now I'm like no
you don't talk to fish command fish I I
I 100% agree with you on that because
the new 52 Aquaman got me back into
Aquaman and I loved it and and I I
remember the first the first issue and
and you probably know it too when he's
sitting in the restaurant and he orders
fish and chips exactly and everyone
gasped and they're like you can't do
that you talk to fish and he's like I
tell them what to do you can't have a
convers ation with a fish see that that
was something I thought was funny
because when I went through and I read
the new 52 Justice League when Aquaman
First shows up and like the sharks
attack you know those uh those parad
demons like I think flash or somebody
was like he's like did you talk to those
fish and he was like he's like I can't
talk to him he's like I can suggest
things to them right I'm like okay look
basically like he's communicating with
fish I don't care how you want to paint
it out if he suggests they do things or
if he tells them go attack this thing
like he's speaking fish the fish
Whisperer yeah
Whisperer the situation of aaman is a
great marketing study actually because
you think about it 1970s is when that
whole aaman the reason he has a comic is
because he's popular and he does things
not because they thought it would be
funny no no the's not a joke right in
1970s he had the Super Friends and he
got painted everyone in the Super
Friends got painted in more of a
kid-friendly light light-hearted jokey
way but Aquaman was the guy riding the
seahorse with with Aqualad and doing
stupid things and that just seems to
have carried over into Robot Chicken
into Family Guy it's just been
repeatedly brought up in pop culture
that's mostly Pro that my for my guess
is because Aquaman never had a Dark
Knight Returns like no Batman was a joke
1966 that show like that's how people
still refer to Batman depending on what
demographic or age goup you're talking
about they're like oh B pop pow Zam like
shut up like that was 80 years
ago but then Tim Burton made dark like
well actually Frank Miller does Dark
Knight Returns and then Tim Burton does
Batman 1989 like so Frank Miller
convinces the comic book reading
Community like hey no it's not [__]
and then Tim Burton legitimizes Batman
as being like a dark cool character and
suddenly Batman's cool again like he
goes from being like a joke to being
cool and like Superman had like a crazy
great movie after like a bunch of silly
serials from the 50s and like radio
dramas and but even then like even the
max fer cartoon he was like awesome and
cool and serious but like even Superman
was treated seriously in fact I actually
think I think like the culture kind of
like craps on Superman a little bit more
today or rather in the last 15 20 years
because those Superman movies got really
dumb and like Aquaman never had like a
reckoning there was never like a really
cool public display of Aquaman's
coolness and like that's kind of I think
the failing like it's it's why there's
why he's always the go-to punching bag
like you know well I mean a lot of
superheroes got we had the Batman
cartoon that revived Batman because a
lot of the big heroes right now are who
is popular in the cartoons in our day
and age so we had the Batman one
Batman's popular Superman had a great
cartoon that we watched that one then we
had the Justice League cartoon and we
had no
Aquaman we didn't he I think he's in one
episode of Justice League it's like a
two-parter he shows up he's really
badass and the just goes back he's also
in the Superman Animated Series in the
same same thing like he's cool and then
leaves and you never see him again but
it's it's actually really funny I'm this
is a fun fact which you you guys may or
may not have known but did you guys know
the 1960s Batman helped keep the uh
comic from being canceled yeah save the
comic book like which is funny because
like yeah it it saves it and then kind
of Dooms it to being a silly stupid
comic for a long time interestingly
enough back then Neil Adams was doing
like crazy adult stuff with Batman so
you had that silly dumb cartoon and then
kids are going to the com or like the
news stands and they're like I'd like a
Batman comic and you have like stories
where Batman is like having sex with
Talia al goul and then fighting the r in
the desert and being stabbed to death by
scorpions and you're like what is
happening and it looks like it looks as
serious as Prince Valiant and you're
like this is not for children no I don't
know see like people in the comments are
saying like the 1990s Batman the cartoon
is like the definitive Batman and I
agree like that's the Batman I was
raised on like like that and the mark
Hill Joker like that the very the voices
are definitive Kevin Conroy and Mark
Hamill have no have no rival in my eyes
well the thing with the Batman cartoon
and I think it's so perfect is they they
kept him dark but they didn't make him
so dark kids couldn't watch it oh yeah
they had that perfect line where you'd
have like adults would get some inner
jokes and we could see like a darker
side but then Batman would team up with
the Boy Wonder and go take out the crook
and you're like yeah Batman it's funny
because like I think that I think that
uh
art in general thrives in like when it's
forced in a box so it's like forced to
be creative and like the people who made
that show were clearly like I want to
make a show about Batman like the Batman
I like like the cool Batman that like
kills people but the sensor is like we
can't have him kill people okay he's not
g to kill people but like this the
villain's really dark like the Joker is
a maniac and like well he cast to be
like more of like a a scary Nar duel so
they're like okay and so the Batman
series this amazing distillation of all
the things they wanted to do and had to
be very subtle about it so like subtlety
became like a main say of that cartoon
and that's kind of my issue now like we
we're talking about this off camera like
the the new the new direction of DC
animation I feel like the sensors are
gone and they're like oh like now we can
do what we wanted to do and it's like no
you kind of needed parameters and like
so that's kind of like I feel like it's
it's lost a little bit of charm because
it's like if you get that there's an
amazing Batman the animated series book
from a while ago and it has like all
these great sketches and commentaries by
Paul De and Bruce Tim where they talk
about the process of making the Batman
cartoon and you and you're like how did
this happen and even more so how did
Batman Beyond even get close to maid but
like the the you talk they talk about
like fighting against the sensors and
like you get little notes of like the
sensors like okay so when Harley Quinn
says I made a mess on your cape you have
to heavily imply she threw up and it's
like what like and they had to rail
against that every time and so like
everything that happened in that show
was just this this this battle so like
every episode was like a fight to get
made so every episode is really precious
yeah which is why that show I think is
so great yeah every episode well and see
it wasn't the show itself was really was
fun to watch but for me it was like the
small stories that just come out of left
field like the laughing fish all right
based on B on the story The Joker's
entire scheme is to turn fish into Joker
fish and then copyright thing yeah he
wants to copyright fish that's that's it
like that's that's it that's the scheme
that's it that's all there is to that's
one of the that's one of the most
hardcore Joker episodes that show yeah I
loved it I mean like he literally hits
Batman with to in in the head with a
wrench during and then gets eaten by a
shark yeah and then he uh what is it he
drives what God I can't remember what it
was your guy's memory is way too good I
know I was think the same thing I'm
like I don't remember this episode at
all I remember right now like one of my
favorite ones is um God there was one
where um Joker dispersed the laughing
gas across the whole city yeah and um
one of one of my favorite moments is
like him and the henchman and Captain
clown are getting off the boat captain
clown Captain clown I love Captain clown
but but they're get off the boat
and they're pushing grocery carts and uh
he looks at the camera and he says when
the when the going gets tough the tough
go shopping
yeah the only thing I honest remember
like memory-wise from the Batman
animated series I remember enjoying it
but I don't remember any episodes the
only thing I remember is one scene where
Batman was riding on top of an invisible
car he's
flying it's a dead beat dad and he
steals an experimental suit that gives
you cancer because he wants to see his
daughter He makes himself invisible in
the process and just starts going I
don't even know how I don't even know
the rest of the episode I just remember
him flying by he makes he makes an
actual suit out of it like a bodysuit
and so around and committing crime I
remember I remember there's a bum on the
staircase and he's like Batman flies now
I thought that was something Superman
did didn't know he could
fly I loved I'd loved so many God there
was funny thing is I love um we were I
was thinking about like bringing up the
Fantastic Four trailer which we won't
because who cares but like the uh well I
think some people are asking for it
can't over maybe maybe but like um we as
comic book fans are so spoiled now where
we're like we want Spider-Man in The
Avengers like you have eight Avenger
like you have characters like why do
Spider-Man I'm one of them by the way
but like I'm still like I'm aware of the
fact that I'm really spoiled it's it's
not even that though it's like not only
do we need Spider-Man in The Avengers
but we also get a Spider-Man movie every
few years even if they're horrible we're
still getting them by the way like I
liked a lot of the stuff that happened
in that sequel like the suits finally
right they got the eyes right Gwen
Stacy's great like the Rhino's cool uh
oh Spider-Man is funny you know there's
a lot of things that work really well in
that movie um and yet we all hate it and
it's like what are you like you don't
even know like it take it 10 years ago
you would never be getting a Spider-Man
movie every two years I remember I
remember when the when the teaser came
out and it was like with the twin towers
and the web and
the and you're like and I was like wait
really because for the last 20 or 15 20
years everyone had told me that that's
never going to happen and because the
internet was it was
2002 there was no internet like or there
was internet but like it wasn't nearly
as like comic reporting was like was was
relegated to wizard magazine so like Wiz
there was no argu there was no article
about this in Wizard magazine so like we
were blown away by that and we were
really thankful to just see Spider-Man
and like going back to the Batman and
made series we're watching Batman and no
point do I think man would this show be
better with Superman in it like I like
Superman and it would be really and then
they did a crossover well they didn't
even do that for like four seasons that
show show and there's one episode in
like season 2 when they switched over to
Batman Superman Adventures or I'm sorry
the Batman and Robin Adventures when it
the they steal a a derivative of the
clock King's time machine thing that
makes them go go faster through time or
whatever and Robin says like faster than
a speeding bullet and it's at that point
that the show finally acknowledges the
yes maybe you want you might see
Superman one day and it made all of us
go like oh like I I can ask for these
like I can expect these kinds of things
and then when Superman debuted on Warner
Brothers and like the first episode
somebody says well at least he's not
that nut from Gotham City and we're like
what and then Warners bought the show
and brought it to Warner Brothers and
then it became that and then we got like
two lousy crossovers out of it but see
like I think you're right like like if
people ask the question and they say hey
like when are we going to get Spider-Man
for the Marvel Cinematic Universe people
are like well I mean but you have like
Thor and the Incredible Hulk and Iron
Man it's like yeah but it's not it's not
Spider-Man you're getting three new
Avengers in this new movie in this
sequel you're getting three more
Avengers each of them one of them being
a robot and and everyone's like yeah but
when will a character who's only been an
Avenger for the shortest amount of time
get to right you're right the one who
only got to be an Avenger like three
years ago like it was longer ago than
you think it's actually surprising like
there are a lot of people who got into
Comics like recently who have who have
never known Spider-Man to not be an
Avenger
which is mindbending in of itself as far
as Comics go that was a big deal when he
got to be one and he made it I got an
Avengers card and I got a paycheck let
me let me just say he had an Avengers
card before that but he was a
reservist he was a reserv pointing that
out there he did have an Avengers card
but I think I think you're using Serv a
little too Loosely I think he was more
of a like a cheerleader they No Cap gave
him a Avengers card and he when things
then they never called him just so you
know just so you know Deadpool is now on
The Avengers because he dragged Tony
Stark away from the axis yeah am I an
Avenger Now The Avengers cares like no
nothing matters about nothing matters so
this is a great segue I think at this
point to go into and I I know we only
briefly mentioned if we were going to
touch on this but I'm just looking for
Segways Scott since you haven't been
able to get a word in edgewise between
the three of us no what was your
opinions on fantastic Forest trailer did
you actually get a chance to watch it
yet I did watch it uh I tweeted a
picture of it I don't know if any of you
guys saw it but basically my favorite
screenshot is that thing at the end when
they're all standing together looking up
at the beam of light and you can see and
because I'm such a weirdo I took it into
Photoshop and I enhanced it that thing
not wearing any pants yeah I heard about
that like I saw that on Reddit or
something like that it was on some news
website and they were like the thing's
not wearing pants and I was like oh my
God is this gonna be like another like
Dr Manhattan like he's just walking
around with his
junk he better not have a Rock penis
just swinging penis just
swinging oh boy I didn't like that with
M like come on can't Dr Manhattan just
wear something I I get comic book He's
supposed to be naked I'm cool with that
but now we're in movie format no it
completely corrupts the point of the
story like Dr Manhattan has to be naked
because he doesn't care like he's above
nakedness he doesn't even notice he's
naked like yeah well I'm not above
nakedness
well so okay so outside of the the the
potential Rock uh uh uh thing being nude
uh what did you think of the trailer
Scott I thought it was it looked pretty
I'll say that um other than that I
really don't have an opinion on it it
was just kind of exists now I mean up
until this point I I made I made a joke
that I still think the Fantastic 4 movie
is a rumor because we haven't gotten
anything from it yeah all we have is a
trailer a fan trailer that somebody
snuck
on exactly but now we finally have an an
official trailer and it
looks you know it it looks like it's
going to be a movie I'll say
that it looks like it's gonna be the
Fantastic Four that we've seen before
see see you know what all right you know
I'll just go ahead and sayon that I'll
just go ahead and break man I'll break
it down like a fraction here's the
problem fox loves screwing stuff up see
here's here's what fox here's what fox
does fox is given a gift all right fox
is like hey here's this really cool
awesome gift and this gift is really
unique and this gift is really fun and
we can use this gift to do incredible
things but instead let's just take a
mallet and just start hammering on it
and see give that give that m to the
director of Barbershop and then let him
make two
movies that's that's what fox does fox
loves taking something awesome and
screwing it up and that's what they did
like the fan you got the Fantastic 4 the
original superhero family in Marvel
modeled after the Justice League all
right and what do they do they make two
crappy movies
and now they're making a third one which
only Silver
Surfer I didn't like rise of the sil you
know what I I would rather stab myself
in the face with a rusty butter knife
and sit down and watch R the Silver
Surfer again here's the thing that movie
okay those movies are not as bad as like
Punisher war zone but like they're not
great but like at at least they try to
have a good time the one like they're at
least trying to have fun making that
movie like those the characters are like
the character interactions I think were
really faithful to the to to the
characters Dr Doom's a pile of garbage
like no question the stories are
incredibly weak there's really lazy
casting in those movies especially the
second one with that General like you
need a general you're not going to like
and he's going to be against R Richards
cast that guy it's what I call the
Michael iron side effect we need a guy
who no one can trust and hates the
protagonist C Cast Mike Len side no oh
wait no wait wait
wait stop under no cumstances under no
circumstances is it ever acceptable to
talk bad about Michael ironide Mich man
and everything that he did up until the
90s was gold okay but I'm saying in the
last 10 years he's in Terminator
Salvation he's an X-Men first Class he
plays that General he plays the fraking
naval captain and you're like why is he
in this because he needs to be a god
that is has that is Gruff that you don't
necessarily trust who doesn't like the
protagonist and like it's just lazy
casting he built his amazing career
anyway Michael G has his rules also
definitive voice for dark side but hold
on he played the voice of dark side in
the C in the Superman Animated Series in
Justice League he he better be the voice
when they finally get when they get dark
not gonna do
that they're gonna cast someone dumb
like Ben Cumberbatch will play dark P
comes out playing Dark Side and they'll
moap his
face I can totally see that with the
accent the full British accent or
yeah like it'll be no I I I agree like I
I love Michael iron's side as much as
the next guy but but sounds right like
he is this generic guy he's like we need
one
role him in Total Recall or scanners or
even Starship Troopers it's the exact
same that it's the exact same situation
that Samuel Jackson is now it's like we
need a badass black guy Samuel
Jackson he's almost Nicholas Cage and
that he will say yes to any almost
anything you Capital One card I'm your
man Jackson you're a model of Integrity
uh but like those those uh those
fantastic before movies are garbage uh
but at least they're having a good time
Qui shout out to variant comics in our
CH hey what going on
um but that trailer was just the fox
cation of Mo of C of comic book movies
like what they say in that trailer from
the direct from the from the studio that
brought you days Future Past you're like
okay because that movie was super serial
and needed to fix all the terrible
decisions that fox had made with that
franchise so don't forget that second uh
there's not there's nothing fun or joy
about that movie from the trailer like
my opinion is it will probably be more
Dark Night more like it's real and it's
dark and it's like serious and who wants
to see that like it's like John Hickman
like the Fantastic Four where no one's
happy and everyone's a
murdered blowing up planets that's what
it feels like to me like go we have to
destroy worlds I'm sorry no there's
nothing yeah there's no great or good
it's I have to do this like I'm going to
build a bridge to death no yeah like it
just you know I mean like and by the way
like they're changing the origins like
they're not going to space they're going
to another dimension yeah supposedly
they're going Negative Zone fine I don't
care about that you know am I the only
person that's fine with that and I'm
gonna say I'm fine Reinventing my
superheroes for the big screen as long
as you don't get stupid about it yes
you're not going to give me 20 years of
fantastic for history you're not going
to give me a valid origin story that I'm
I'm happy with and not spend 3 hours
trying to tell it to me no that's the
thing like I don't care like who does
like why do we need all these
Origins know who the Fantastic war is
I'm sorry Scott go ahead oh I was just
gonna say that's that's something that
I've been frustrated with uh with uh
comic book movies lately is like they
spend so much time on Origins and I'm
like just I would appreciate it if you
would do like a really quick Montage at
the beginning or like a voiceover like
this is what happened to us get everyone
on track and then move on with the story
that's what I would appre that is
literally they do that they do that in
the Spider-Man movies yeah they open up
with like the the flip of what happened
what Spiderman 2 did that was a context
thing that was like Amazing Spider-Man
the whole damn 50 minutes on yeah the
origin and I'm like dude you don't even
like if you when when Marvel gets the
rights back to give a big middle finger
to that studio they should just
literally have a comic book like a
really big CG comic flip and you just
see panels drawn by Steve ditco of like
SP spider bite Uncle Ben like Spider-Man
done like we get it yeah on board the
top three origin stories that
anybody you know richest person homeless
people know are Superman Batman and
Spider-Man so like you we get it we
don't need to waste another 80 million
on a freaking on another on another
Uncle Ben
cting in the uh in The Incredible Hulk
movie with Edward Norton they did that
if you remember open credits they cover
the nobody cares about Hulk and they
were like ah get to The
Hulk punching yeah they they had they
okay people know how the Fantastic 4
become the Fantastic 4 they go into
space cosmic ray powers like everybody
know we know that I guarantee you when
people go to that movie they're gonna be
like I didn't even know there was a
fantastic 4 no yeah go ahead go ahead I
was just gonna say I I usually have some
sort of like a litmus test with my
sister I'll be like do you cuz she's she
doesn't read Comics so I'll be like do
you know these characters like I told
her about the Fantastic 4 trailer today
and she was just like oh that's neat are
the Fantastic 4 like X-Men is that what
they are yeah I mean like that's I don't
know maybe I give the regular person I
don't I don't know maybe I assume I
might assume too much here but I always
figured like like there's there's
Mainstays in the comic book Community
who just been there for so long that
people just know who they are Superman
Batman Spider-Man Wolverine maybe the
Fantastic 4 aren't aren't that I don't
think so I don't think they
are they used to be but I don't think
they ever really like reached that point
and that's sad because they're Marvel's
first family a Marvel fan is like I know
exactly who that is and they were
important like them canceling that book
is like an affront to Marvel itself oh
god well you know why they that well
it's all well because they don't want to
help won't give them the rights back
that's the only reason why they're doing
that by the way
like you can have Fantastic 4 if we can
have Dr Doom like I'll take if we could
just have Dr Doom so the Avengers can
fight
I'll agree with that yeah can we get
Galactus while we're at it though can we
get like a two two deal I want Galactus
more than Dr actually I'll take Galactus
you know just give us the villains
except the Box knows like okay you can
have galatis who's left there are two
characters you can have the moleman you
have Dr uh we'll also take annihilist by
the way like imagine what you could do
if you had anilist because then you got
the Negative Zone and then you've got
Annihilation done and done all you have
to do is I don't speak of annihilation
because I I don't know bet there's
somebody in your window
what oh that's a TV no that's that's a
game that's dying dude this whole time
next to a window and it looked like
there were legs going by I'm like oh
no the some your window um yeah so I
mean we're way out way out a totally
different tangent here and it's
perfectly fine what do you think Benny
Benny and Rob what are your opinions of
this teaser I I liked it I I I you know
what cuz because a while ago I kind of
went into these because I was that comic
book fan like you that went into you
ruined it you ruined my origin I knew
this and you know what a while ago I
accepted that they're going to change
everything and I kind of like the
changes to the Fantastic 4 I mean you
got to and you know what I think no
one's touched on this no one has
mentioned this and I know it's it's been
a humongous issue amongst the combook
community Johnny Storm's black and no
one has mentioned that and I think I'm
the only person in the world who is
apparently okay with that well people
freaked out in the beginning but then
they were like but then they realized
how racist they sound and they that's
exactly what it is Johnny Storm needs to
be blond hair blue eyes and
oh do the my complaint isn't so much
that he's black it's that that he's no
longer Susan Storm's brother even even
if you say he's adopt well no even if
you say he's adopted and stuff it's it's
the the biological brother sister thing
has always been their thing well here's
the thing like that that that's an
Antiquated notion and like now that
family is totally different than it was
in 1964 like they could legitimately he
could but like you know what be cool if
they don't even
say like they don't even address like
because you know there's going to be a
line where he's like you know ever since
my mom married your dad like some dumb
horrible expository line to explain it
like we will then like we will know
because you know that like some jerk off
producer is like but people are going to
really have a problem with it they need
to know why as opposed to just like
don't address it who cares if you want
to know then you're a jackass like
moving on that' be really cool I think
also com it's funny we have nerdsync on
here and I'm shouting at the other
channels by the way go to nerdsync
Productions but Joel from comic book
cast uh says that people are still
freaking out over the Johnny Storm thing
if you read the comments on the trailer
they're still freaking out of the Johnny
Storm thing and and what it really what
it really boils down to is I mean it
boils down to when these characters are
created in the 1960s would you have ever
pictured a Miles Morales Spider-Man hell
no no way that's why Luke Black Panther
and black panther is named after a
racial organization
it's not even that he's an original
character oh Panthers are cool and I
want to do that no like Stanley was
looking out the window and he saw them
protesting and he's like that sounds
like a superhero that's that's oh my God
that's not what
happened I know I'm just saying sounds
like a comic misconception is a comic
misconception like that's there you go
there's your episode you're welcome I
thank you all right I'm gonna take not
he yeah like he came he came he came
like months it was less than a year or
maybe it was a year or something like
that he was within two years but he
showed up before the Black Panther Party
but no that's see that's that's the
funny thing is you go you watch like any
like major news shows or anything like
that like turn on CNN Headline News
something like that they're like oh my
God you know Johnny Storm's black and
then somebody will be like is that a
problem like do you have a problem with
black people and all a sudden they're
like well no I mean you know it's just
you know he's not like that in
comics yeah I my issue like if I if I
were to have an issue with Johnny Storm
being being black it's more that I have
an issue with them arbitrarily changing
things from the comic but I also happen
to know that Michael B Jordan's a great
actor and I like seeing him so I'm happy
with that like if it was just if it was
an excuse like if like the guy they cast
was the director's brother or girlfriend
or something like I'd be like that's the
problem like but you know just getting
the right person for the right role is
top priority so that works well and and
I I'll always say this about about
Michael V Jordan like he was really good
and Chronicle but to me the best
performance that Michael B Jord never
put on was an episode of house and he
was was a kid who was blind and he uh
somehow there was some kind of illness
or something like that and it threatened
to take his uh his hearing and so he
would have been blind and deaf and it
was like his character dealing with this
but it was a freaking amazing episode
and it's best performance I ever saw him
put on but um make a black I already
that was a really good episode people
are asking me to do black panther
explain I already did that black panther
explain guys guys black panthers none of
us are doing it Scott is gonna do one
now that we volunteered him apparently I
am yeah why not
by the way if you want to know where
Scott's channnel is you should go to
nerding Productions see Scott if you
can't plug your stuff I got you covered
man thank you so much for that um for
some reason YouTube won't let me post
links in the chat and I don't know why
but I don't know it's very weird I mean
since it's like my chat okay we
discussed the movie um and in the end I
think all of us the problem with the
trailer is it really is just a teaser
they barely show anything and we know
what we've all heard and the fact of the
matter is this it's going to be a
horrendous movie it's going to be a
mediocre mov it's going to be a
horrendous movie like the original
Fantastic 4 movie The Roger Corman
Fantastic 4 movie it's be like
thata the only person that saves it it's
GNA be a mediocre movie like X-Men Days
of the Future Past where we all sitting
there said that wasn't horrible but you
could have done so much better thought
was cool that that cleaned it up and
like let it let everybody take a bow
with Grace and dignity that was nice I
like that mov hold on are we tearing
down days of f like the Days of Future
Past movie and he just just did I my
opinion da of future pass is not a bad
movie but it could have been so much
freaking
better yeah how could it like you want
to see pride into the past instead of
Wolverine I mean no no no I'm I'm fine
with them doing the Wolverine thing but
the whole going into the first class and
dealing with first class and and
Wolverine is now a primary character
that they only put in there for the
simple facts of the matter if we have to
have Wolverine in there because if you
actually think about it Wolverine did
absolutely nothing he did nothing he
shot up and said we need to build the
group then you have Quicks silver show
up for a cameo but no let's bring the
fastest man in the world let's not bring
him to go fight against the president
guys you go off and over here and
Wolverine you're useless we're just
going to throw you into the water oh no
now we're going to go free the guy who's
the worst villain in the world does that
make any sense to you like you know what
Scott give us your take on the whole
days of future P thing you know uh I
think we did a I think we did a podcast
review of it and the the very the very
um gist of it is I think I really
enjoyed a lot of the future stuff and I
wish they had done had a better balance
between future and past yeah and that
was that was basically my biggest
complaint about the movie but I mean it
wasn't horrible my opinion is that it
could have been so much better it just
it feels to me like Daisy future pass
they read the book and they said what
are the coolest elements make those
prominent don't care about why it makes
sense or Not by the way we got to beat
Marvel to the punch with Quicksilver
even though that's not going to make any
sense continuity wise put quicksilver in
the thing no the Quicksilver thing the
scene was really awesome and I hope that
Avengers has a scene almost as cool as
that
that actor I really don't like so good
luck with that but like you know I don't
know like like one of the this is
something that somebody had um somebody
had mentioned and it was really
something that I noticed I guess when I
went back and watched it went back and
watched the trailers for trailer for
Avengers 2 Age of Ultron yeah one of the
things people said is that it didn't
look like Quicksilver was moving that
fast like not not in a slow motion scene
but there's a scene where like he L
really runs up but the problem is scene
yeah and you're not given any context we
don't know how far away he was
like when he ran up there I mean if he
was on like the other side of the
country well then he's fast as hell but
the thing people always have to remember
too is that when it comes to Quicks I
think they like Marvel has explicitly
said his speed is like 175 miles hour
it's not flash levels it's not flash
levels so he's not he's not in one place
and another and like the blink of an eye
unless your teren Crystal Quicks over
then there's a whole another level of
speed yeah then new time travel nobody
talks about son of
them okay you know what I'm a hole I'm G
put the hole in your Quicksilver thing
the quick the cool scene in that movie
for quicker when he pretty much slowed
down time and ran around made absolutely
positively no sense unless first off the
bullets don't just knock out of the way
because you're moving faster than them
they still have a trajectory and
everything like that secondly the UN the
the music track that he's listening to
would had to have been sped up to like I
did yeah I agree I mentioned
that like how F all right let me put
this thing on super hypers speed sounds
like Jers you but I can hear it
yeah like it's the coolest scene ever I
don't deny that but it felt more like it
should have been on the Matrix we're
going to break
reality I mean that see to me th I don't
worry about stuff like that like oh my
God the music's not the right pace okay
no it makes a cool scene but that
doesn't I mean we're talk we're talking
about my problems with the movie The
problem is that that scene made no sense
whatsoever for super speed I am a flash
fan you know how you know how they do
flash the speed super speed right watch
The Flash show that's how you do speed
right okay just like a red blur yeah I
don't
know um here was my question about the
whole Days of Future Past thing if if
you're contention here totally off topic
but okay using using uh using specific
using I guess uh like what what do they
call those like uh dime words or nickel
words or whatever that is if you're
contention here is that the music was
didn't didn't actually match up with the
continuity say like the music was just
too slow too fast or whatever then how
would you have done it would you have
just not put music in that scene no
don't put music in there that that that
right there messes with the entire
because here's the thing here's the
thing because the way they treated it
was like Quicksilver stopped time that's
how they treated it they didn't treat it
like he moved fast we treated it like he
was able to slow down time cuz he
actually stopped moving and started
moving things out of the way which
basically because in motion yes he would
have speed but when you stop wait is he
just just stand the like like that like
that doesn't make any sense he doesn't
stop time he moves quickly and that's
how they treated it they treated it like
he stopped time popped his music on and
just did what he wanted yeah well you
know what the only the only way I could
have seen that being different is if
like once say once like the cops start
to pull the triggers like they slow down
when they pull the triggers he puts his
things on and then they immediately cut
to the scene when all the cops fall down
all that kind of stuff and he's just
like yeah that was me but you don't
actually happens but that would have
been more that not have been cool that
would have been cool no like holy crap
this guy's awesome I it would have been
kind of boring because I mean you'd just
be like well you know it's what well the
entire scene was a joke he pops on music
and moves like the glasses moves a guy's
fist over to the right in order for
quick over to grab a guy's arm and push
it over here with his momentum would not
have been it would have been like this
guy the
room oh my God so clearly we need
someone to break down the physics of
this
scene I like on an episode of like V
sauce or something that's where I got my
anger from like a V sauce 3 episode or
something I don't know oh wow well I'm
just shouting everyone out comic book
cast nursing Productions Vsauce very in
comics I mean we we need like
MythBusters to step in on on this and
that would be the greatest podcast ever
that would have been awesome we had like
MythBusters on here it's like okay guys
let's let's perform an experiment live
and see if it would
work all right all right we're we're
completely off topic how about we move
on to the uh secret War situation and
get Scott's opinion on the Marvel
Universe and it's complete and total
Annihilation reboot I'm on board that's
my that's myv all right then next
topic no I mean I've always uh I talked
about this before I think on a on a
podcast I know I'm like referencing
things that I know people haven't
listened to but um yeah so uh my thing I
have a problem with like Marvel's
timeline and everything it always
confuses me uh where you can have Comics
that show Spider-Man and like uh way
back in the day then you have uh Comics
showing that his origin only took place
13 years ago and even still people had
iPhones or something I don't know it was
like their timeline is super confusing
to me so uh I'm I'm I'm totally on board
with just them completely rebooting
that's what that's what this is right
it's just like a complete reboot yeah
it's like a they they haven't actually
officially said so yeah you know I I do
I agree with you on that I do because
Marvel the problem I have DC basically
once the timelines get too far apart and
it makes doesn't make any sense they
just do a crisis and they just reboot
everything and then it's like oh
Superman was only came around 5 years
ago yeah we had technology and stuff
then but Marvel it's like no the origin
I mean I just pulled up the Iron Fist
origin to do my Origins thing and the
original Comics it's still hold
basically Danny Ran's from like 1970
like like that doesn't make any sense
guys and you know and he's going to the
middle of the Himalayas with Tibetan
Monks and stuff like that and in a day
and age when his family got rich off us
some weird thing it doesn't make any
sense he started Heroes for hire and all
that stuff like like here's okay here is
the problem with the whole Marvel
continuity like Benny makes a really
good point the fact that they don't
reboot things yeah like it all just it
all just kind of stays the same Marvel
has a sliding time skill which is how
they've adapted to all that yeah and so
it took Peter Parker like like what
almost 20 years to graduate from high
school and college or something like
that according to that well like he
graduated like he graduated from high
school and college in real time like he
in like he he was created 4 and like in
70 whatever he was graduating from
college and they were like uh
oh wait a minute hold them back a few
years 30 see like like to me like I tie
all and I I did that during during my
video I tie all that into Franklin
Richards like to me that's all Franklin
Richards fault like Franklin Richards
froze the Marvel Universe in place and
nobody ever gets old they all just you
need to make a video about that this is
my
legitimate I already I already oh yeah
not you whatever I don't like your stuff
Scott hey you need to make a Franklin
Richard explanation like how the time do
you even know that theory I don't
actually know that the theory is that
time time in Marvel moved normal until
the birth of Franklin Richards and then
due to the fact that his father was a
hero once Franklin Richards hit a
certain age he kept basically holding
everyone back from aging anymore Marvel
you moved properly until that point so
at that point basically because of how
powerful he is he he holds time and
place and he constantly resets and moves
time around to always have you know his
father be a hero with his superhero
friends and that's why Franklin Richards
will suddenly be 18 then he'll be
suddenly six and then he'll be suddenly
12 it's a kid who never grew up and like
has the power of a God and it's why
Spider-Man is he always young because
like Spider-Man's his favorite superhero
so he always like preserves Spider-Man
in that state and like he won't let the
universe die it's very like there's a
show called Saint elsewhere where there
was like the show ends spoilers for sure
a in the8 the uh snow globe the snow
globe the autistic boy and there are so
many crossovers into that show that like
every show that crossed over with St
Elsewhere which includes like Law and
Order
yep and like the Bob newart show like
everything that ever cross over St
Elsewhere is part of that Universe it's
in like this boy's
imagination and that's how the Marvel
universe is for Franklin Richards it's
like it's all part of this man booy's
desire to preserve his dad's like
perfect life yeah and and you see it and
you see it play out like this this is
the stuff that I covered like you see it
play out like Franklin Richards was the
eye of his parents eye and then his mom
got pregnant with Valeria Richards and
then suddenly Valeria Richards went away
and then when Franklin Richards got to
an age where he was ready to have a
sister suddenly Valeria Richards comes
back right he's like you know what it
was really it was really Petty of me to
let my mom have a miscarriage I'm gonna
make that never happen yeah he he he
like rebooted like he well the Marvel
kind of rebooted the universe but kind
of didn't with the Heroes Reborn yeah
Heroes Reborn they they rebooted
characters but then they also
established they
didn't after Onslaught all like a bunch
of characters that didn't sell very well
but were really popular got put into a
ultimate type Universe where Rob leld
and Jim Lee drew them and then they came
back and they were young and
interesting I mean that was did you you
ever check out Heroes Reborn
Scott uh I don't think so D okay like it
was literally a universe inside ball the
um it was what Marvel tried to do what
it was what what it was Marvel's
ultimates line but before they had the
balls to actually just do that like they
were like let's make all the characters
young and interesting revise their
Origins but like so they just took those
characters and put them in a pocket
Universe where that happened as opposed
to ultimates where like Casada said like
no there's no Universe thing it's funny
actually how much everything is going
back against that like now but Casada
editor-in Chief at the time was like no
there's a p we may we published this
book called ultimates and that's where
things happen it's not going to cross
over because that's not they're not
universes like he had a real problem
with the Marvel 616 he's like no it's
Marvel one it's the main Universe where
everything happens and matters like
that's like he really he like had
editorial mandates where he's like don't
call it 616 like that's not anything
like yeah it's not the 66th Universe
it's the first one number one one that
matters and I think they're probably
going to like reboot it and make it one
but anyway
uh DC they always make DC whatever
Universe were in well now that's Earth
one that's the main worth that's what we
now it's the new for the two now it's
the you know and that old Earth you like
they're like 49 like they're 49 now yeah
and uh and and so like Heroes were born
was basically them trying out Ultimate
Marvel but in
continuity and uh and it and it wasn't
really well received no it was was it
was Marvel did a Marvel did a piss poor
job doing it too because a lot of the
characters rebooted in a way where
nobody cared and and the way they did it
is they basically just had like this uh
I can't remember her name but she was a
Celestial and she showed up to Franklin
Richards and she was like you have to
choose between one you can't have both
and so we actually enters the universe
he made and he was he he went he goes to
uh to Susan storm and and um Reed
Richards and it's like I don't know what
to do and they're like just do the right
thing and I'm like what really and so
he's like okay I pick the main universe
and then he brings that Universe like he
brings them all back to life in the main
universe but like as those versions but
like they kind of merged them it was
very weird um but like cool drawings uh
that's also where you get that's also
you get Rob LEL drew a version of
Captain America that is the biggest joke
ever yep that's the version of Captain
America that they had in Heroes are born
where he also put like the the the like
Nazi Eagle on Captain America's cowl and
like replace the a but he didn't know
that's what it was he was like oh put
put an eagle there and you were like
that's America that's what they used in
Germany in
1930s that's you don't know anything
idea but that was that's a funny thing
but that's that's all they're really
doing here is Marvel they can paint it
with whatever they want to do they can
call it whatever they want whether they
want to call it consolidating their
universes they're rebooting it all
they're taking all the universes they're
getting rid of the ones that don't
matter they're taking all the famous
stories X-Men 92 which I'm I'm pretty
sure maybe it might be from 91 but it's
X-Men issue number one yeah when um when
and Chris Claremont like it was like the
highest selling X-Men comic ever yeah
the 150 alternate covers yeah it's so
like I think to date it's sold like two
million issues or something stupid like
that but um it's it's super high selling
but anyway they're giving that its own
universe and and they're just taking the
most popular stories and characters and
giving them their own realities or their
own well they're like they're gonna be a
country battle world like okay so
they're basically putting them all in a
battle world they're all going to fight
right now I was doing a little more
research on convergence because we were
a little confused about that so
convergence is all of these multi
Multiverse universes are going to be in
a singular world where they're going to
have to
fight
yep y so so basically the all new Marvel
is their attempt at basically doing New
52 now the difference is and I I'm
pretty sure that's what they're doing
Marvel's planning it already what they
want to keep in continuity while New 52
was like reboot we'll figure it out
later yeah that's wingy yeah and I mean
like it was a cool move for DC to go
like no like Scott Snyder and Greg Capo
you know what you're doing with Batman
just do whatever and like you like and
the guys are working on detective like
you guys know what you're doing do
whatever but don't talk to each other or
plan anything or figure out how those
work and it'll all be in the same
universe and we'll do something over
here with Jeff John's and Jim Lee with
Justice League and that will be in
direct contradiction with everything
like make a make a freaking map right on
the wall and then stop like have you
ever seen like those like those
story here's the issue here's the and
I'm sorry to interrupt you but this is
this is the issue DC can do that yeah
theyve done did that they've done that
with if you during new52 the six Green
Lantern books all worked coherently
together and they made sense well like
there's a they used to do that where
they they had like a year like they had
a big dry rice marker board and they
like wrote down what they did for the
year and like stories and like with
Superman for example like it was all
their titles and then what happened
where it happened and how it happened
and like where things were going to fall
in the stories and like each writer got
like a got dibs and they all had heads
up and that's actually where the death
of Superman came from they like they
would used to make a joke where someone
would always write at the end of the
line and then Superman dies and they
were all
go and then they ran out of goddamn
ideas and they were like what if he did
die at the end
yeah I mean I don't at the end of the
day I'm not really sure I'm not 100%
sure how I feel about this and I think
I've kind of been on the on the fence
about it for a while
um I think in some ways it can be a good
thing because the problem Marvel has is
because they have they've never rebooted
their whole continuity officially like
not like this anyway and because they
had and not like
this like this Avengers
disassembled Hawkeye gets blown up yeah
oh boy I'm not gonna okay so just fun
side note because you guys know I do the
dramatic readings on my channel yes it
was doing the Avengers disassemble
dramatic greeing CU after after fans had
been saying you've been doing dramatic
greeing you love it and I really I was
just reading the scripts and it was an
Avengers of theem I'm like I'm going to
try my handed actually doing this
dramatically and it was that line where
I was like not like this not like this
that was actually one of the First
videos of yours that I ever saw and I
was like I like this this is pretty good
not like this it's just it's one of
those funny moments you know to me it's
I that line like five or six times like
I did the whole script almost in one
take and I got to that and I'm like it's
got to be powerful yeah
I can imagine you like like sitting
there in your place and like psyching
yourself like all right all right say
not like this not like
this oh man but but no I'm I'm kind of
on the fence about it because with all
these different universes and all these
different stories and Marvel apparently
not communicating because Bennie made a
really good point I was talking to
Bennie about Spider-Man and I said you
know what something really weird here is
like while all this is happening
incursions is going on now there's some
point if I remember correctly where Roma
and spiderverse mentions the incursions
but aside from that like that's it
like and no point and this is what I
really think would have tied everything
together really well is if at some point
along the lines like you have silk and
you have spidergwen and you have uh Ana
who are just jumping from reality to
reality and they happen to jump into one
where like the black priests are wiping
out life on a planet and they're like
let's get out of here and like they bail
out like that would have tied into
incursions perfectly but the problem is
Marvel apparently doesn't like
communicate between who's doing like
Spider-Man they're like don't worry
about incursions we'll worry about that
and
yeah it was like I was telling Rob for
the longest time now in sty you can
vouch and I don't I don't know if you're
a Avid father of Spider-Man comics like
I am Scott but Spider-Man's always been
kind of treated like even though like
he's involved in the other books like
he'll show up in Avengers and he'll show
up in the big events yeah the Spider-Man
books themselves have always been almost
treated like a totally separate Universe
like things that happen there would make
perfect s like great example of spider
Island I think the Avengers never even
showed up to the end it was like oh our
whole Island's been taken over by
spiders maybe we should go jump
they did tiin to make to tell that story
yeah right it's like but basically like
everything that happens to Spider-Man
seems to only happen to Spider-Man's
world he doesn't really doesn't affect
anything the the stupid Maximum Carnage
event was 14 Parts where Carnage and
like six D listers destroy Manhattan no
other
book happen Goblin island is a great a
great uh no gotion Goin Nation the Green
Goblin has Tak New York no and the only
Cameo you even get of the other Avengers
doesn't even go into other books the
only Cameo is at one point when he gets
his body back he swings by them and
they're like Spider-Man are you still
evil and he's like I've got this I'll
explain later and that's it like okie
dokie like by the way I I chalk that up
to just Norman Osborne being a toolbox
and being like I set some fires and I
stood on the Brooklyn Bridge and now I'm
in charge
of like like it was actually just two
streets thing like you didn't take any
like who's like the mayor is still in
Gracie Mansion right like there's no
like the cops are still patrolling like
you haven't taken over anything like you
just you just spray painted some walls
and set a few fires you're just a douche
you're just a member of Project Mayhem
like that's not anything I I mean what
do you think Scott I mean do you follow
do you follow Spider-Man concurrently do
you know what's going on with him yeah
so uh I'm I'm a few issues behind but
Spider-Man is my favorite superhero of
all time and I think I agree with you
about just it seems like it's a
completely separate universe and I think
that's probably why I like Spider-Man a
lot is because I i' I've been kind of
discovering as I'm reading more and more
stuff and and doing research for videos
that I'm not a huge fan of like big
events or like crossover team stuff I'm
like more solo hero I want to see what
they're doing with their thing and I
think maybe that's kind of why I like
Spider-Man a lot is because he he
tackles apparently these like really big
things of people taking over the city
and and stuff like that and it's just
like him maybe a couple others but it's
not like the yeah like you were saying
it doesn't look like the Avengers step
in all that much and if they do you know
it's just kind of like a passing
reference well that's the thing like
it's funny how like I think the most
significant Spider-Man influence in any
of the events any of the events in the
last 15 years was Civil
War and it was only just that he took
his mask off in front of cameras and
then never did anything again and then
like tried to fight Iron Man and lost
and then Punisher saved him like that's
kind of it like Secret Wars never does
anything like he never I'm sorry Secret
Wars uh secret Invasion there's a lot of
secrets in the Marvel Universe and there
true but's a secret War he never
actually like has he never like casts a
tie like he never like splits a tie like
he never does any kind of like
influential thing it's it's you know
it's weird it's funny because he's like
he's important he's also like not and
even in the axis event he shows up at
the beginning and he's kind of the guy
that only one whoes get switch right
he's the only one that does get switch
and he's the guy he's like I gotta I
gotta go assemble everyone who didn't
get switched I gotta make a team and he
does it and then it's like it's pretty
much all about Deadpool versus Kid
apocalypse like yeah like okay fine but
like don't do that like we Avengers
versus X-men like he's going to teach
hope about power and responsibility but
like doesn't matter like like get a
couple issues out of it but like it
doesn't actually make any kind of change
in the story um I remember that because
that was actually funny because she he's
like all right hope here's the key words
with great power comes great
responsibility she's like what does that
mean yeah I know
saying for so long I have no
idea see to me that's that's the like
you that's the problem like you got a
character who's a Mainstay in Marvel com
like the face of Marvel entertainment
yep everybody knows who Spider-Man is
even if they don't know who the
Fantastic 4 is they know who Spider-Man
is he's a billion dollar franchise yeah
he's a he's a franchise in of himself if
Marvel got rid of everybody else they
could still have Spider-Man and the
comics would still sell yep all right
yeah the problem here is again to me you
can't have a face and a character that
big and then keep him isolated to his
own world because when you have like
these huge events that go on like with
the incursions right now the question is
why are we not seeing any sance to
what's going on in spiderverse like why
is it not in any way it's literally
interdimensional change like yeah it's
the exact same Concepts as a matter of
fact in spiderverse they will see other
versions like the evil Tony Stark and
the evil Daredevil and like and we've
never heard of an incursion you've got
you've got a villain who's jumping
worlds and they don't even make in a
passing like you don't see like Mor Lon
jumping he jumps in rub he's like oh
another mat maker world and he jumps
out Hees like or like he jumps and like
it's there's nothing he's like oh no the
world was
destroyed no like there's no reference
to bad probably because nobody wants to
[__] probably because nobody
wanto and like the stupid whatever oh my
God man oh my
God the moon and fight
and yeah the we the we the Weaver the
spider Weaver is trying to find a way to
get rid of the the inheritors by having
this elaborate plot with Spiderwoman
right yeah okay why why doesn't he just
go and now you're in a world with the
the black
priest about yeah exactly how about you
all teleport to a world that the
illumini is about to blow the hell up
and I'll teleport you out right before
it happens I mean isn't that what
happened with Neymar hey you're gonna
chill it
here
yeah all right all right so yeah that
that's pretty much that's the Multiverse
situation um I think we're kind of
running to our nor noral time frame here
we got about 15 20 minutes left so you
know what for people who have just
joined us cuz when we opened there was
20 people here and now we have over 300
Scott why don't you tell us once again
about nerd sync sure thing guys um
you're getting it you know Scott I have
no idea what your channel is uh I have
no idea what you do there would you mind
filling me in one more time just
conveniently I forgot oh boy boy would I
um all right so yeah so nerd sing
Productions is a comic book Channel on
YouTube where basically we talk a lot
about um the uh recently be doing a lot
of the behind the scenes of comics like
with the industry what artists and
writers were thinking when they came up
with characters and story lines and
really just kind of the the main show is
Comic misconceptions and and a lot of
times we tackle some misconceptions
sometimes um we teased earlier that I
was doing a Deadpool video and that's
coming out soon enough and it's a really
good one I might I'm I'm tempted to just
tell you the topic right now because I
think it's a really good misconception
about let tease the audience yeah all
right right tease the audience I'm doing
a video in a couple weeks about the
misconception that Deadpool is a ripoff
of uh Deathstroke so because I've found
that he's not and I found sources and
stuff I found the one source that says
that he is and then I found like a bunch
others that says he's not and then some
for some reason people just took that as
like a thing that's like oh yeah he's a
ripoff of death St right and so
hopefully going to be tackling that one
pretty soon and uh just like a whole
bunch of other stuff you know we talk
about sometimes psychological things
like we did the why do people stay in
Gotham and I talked a lot about like
confirmation bias or optimism bias and
uh you know cognitive stuff and it's
yeah I I fascinating to me so if you're
interested in that stuff nerd sync
Productions it's a great Chanel guys um
maybe Scott will be join whenever
Scott's available because we have a very
large scheduling issue getting him on
these shows but he's always welcome to
join us in the show unless Rob hits me
up after this and says nobody it's my
show sounds right never happened you
know when I was in college I was it was
my freshman year in college and I took
Communications 101 and we was like we
were like man you know it's K 101 it's
going to be it's going to be a cake
course it's a one-on-one course how
difficult could it really be it's for
you know required reading and so on and
so forth and man it was a 100%
memorization class and we had this like
we had a binder like that thick actually
I might have it I'll show it another
time but I have that binder around here
somewhere and what we had to do was we
had to go over the concept of
confirmation bias and we had to go over
all those different things and the
psychological effects of colors and
things like that let me tell you
something we spent like 15 hours in WT
Young Library the main library here on
campus studying for that test and I
promise you like I will go the rest of
my life without hearing about
confirmation bias
something but it was it was we learned
anyway you're not gonna be on the show
again I'm sorry that's what I'm hearing
yeah I long version of saying no no no I
I got this i got this Scott you and me
we're going to go make the nerd stink
stink storian podcast sure thing that's
a that's a moneymaking title right there
I think so the nerd stin storian I think
it I think it very clearly says what it
is in the title I think people will
definitely
be so okay you guys are all talking
about it so we might as well acknowledge
it um for those of you guys are
wondering there is a watch Mojo vote
going around right now um watch moo is
assembling a top 10 comic book YouTube
channels and all four of us have been uh
invited to be on it we've all given
permission from our channels to go ahead
and use us and the vote is still going
live at the moment and you should all go
there and just vote comic storan and
ignore everyone
else well that's the thing yeah I was
gonna clarify that Scott there there is
there is a bit of confusion here you can
vote for everyone you like like
everyone's and Scott Scott is I'll tell
the funny story about that in a minute
but you know I'll start okay so so we
all got acknowledged from world watch Mo
they like hey guys we want to make a top
10 comic book channels and we want to
invite you all on there and so we all
kind of played it safe and we were like
oh we're all just not we're just not
going to Tweet we're just going to do
tweet tweeters and that's it we're just
gonna leave it alone and Scott made a
video I did not get this memo about only
about only sticking it to Twitter I did
not get that memo so I was like might as
well make a video about it why not and
then apparently I started a war with
every exactly so he makes a video now
the the ranking if I remember correctly
at the time of you making the video was
if I remember correctly it was it was
like variant comic book cast TV little
house is actually number three number
three for a few months and then it was I
was four Scott was five Marvel explained
was like eight for some weird reason
like the thing was nobody knew about the
list I I will say that way down there
for some
reason so what happened was and this is
from my point of view so we talk and
everything like that and you made a
video and I was checking the vote we all
tweeted and I went out for dinner and I
came back from dinner and Scott's number
three and now I'm five and TV little
house is three h four and I'm like wait
a minute what did Scott do what did
Scott do so I start like going crazy on
the internet I'm like Scott must have
done something there's no way that just
out of the blue everyone showed up for
nerd syn so why not why couldn't that be
a thing you don't know me well you know
what I was prepared if that was the case
because I was like Scott's been here
forever I had a mentality of the people
who have been here forever obviously you
know they probably going to get voted
higher f with that so but I was like I'm
just going to check I'm going to look on
his channel and see if he did
something lo and behold there's the
Scott video and Scott did say go vote
for all of your favorites you can vote
for every single one of them and I was
like okay cool I'm gonna make a video
and I need to do it in a hurry and I
totally forgot to even say
that sure yeah sure that's the
explanation thing and I I put up I'm
like you know what you guys should vote
for a comic story and and if we if we
get in the top three I'll do a live Q&A
for 4 hours and so I put mine up and of
course I shot up the ranks and then
Marvel explains like wait I'm still
number eight and all you people are
making
videos so Marvel Mi blade makes his
video and this SC so mine and he's like
you're bribing that's cheating and I'm
like you started this but this is where
it gets good so Scott and I are having a
little playful fun with it and AIS from
variant sees what's going on and he's
like wait so we're making videos
[Laughter]
now so just terrible because as soon as
he was going to make a video we all know
who would be the winner after that right
right so he just shut up he actually
contacted me on on the thing he's like
is the voting open is it dead I'm like I
think it's closed but I'm not going to
tell you it is just in case it isn't you
end
up um because my my assumption at that
point was that they had already chosen
the winners they just wanted traffic see
the the email sounded like they were
like because they said make sure that
your fans participate in this Vote or
this page with the list so I was like oh
it's probably still open so I'll just
send the link out and make a video and
everything well once they first
contacted us and me and S did a little
bit of research um and you can see a lot
of watch Mojo's interactions with
everybody and from what we saw there it
looked like the whole thing was already
decided because they only contacted 10
direct people and that was it they
didn't go out there they didn't tell a
bunch of people to go do the voting so
it looked like they'd already picked the
list and that's why that's why we
weren't doing videos that's we're like
oh whatever they already picked it yeah
so so arish jumps in and he starts going
back and fourth and I'm like Scott
started like a play like a kid at a
playground I didn't do it yeah cuz
wasn't his comment something like well I
guess it looks like Scott and I need to
make videos and you're like Scott's the
one who started
this and then you jump up you're like
well I don't have as much Twitter and
then and then basically just trying to
complain and make excuses that you guys
should stop and let me win that's Bic
what I was saying so but it was funny
cuz like varant didn't make a video
actually he put out a different video
and I'm like oh maybe he's not going to
do it maybe maybe we're going to win
this with like you know it'll be it'll
be me Marvel explained Scott and then
it'll be comic cast and then variant
well no I mean if you're fa comics with
that big of an audience you're not gonna
not do
that so he made most professional
looking one out of all of us yeah he did
like it had perfect sound quality
perfect camera work everything yep Y and
he offered HS which totally beats on my
bribe see that see that to me that I
think is what did it he said that
anybody who votes for me like I'll give
you hugs and ultimately I'm pretty sure
that like the promise of hugs is really
what just sent him over the top yeah I
can't compete with that strong
motivation yeah so so that that's the
story of the watch Mojo voting situation
I think at this point it's kind of
calmed down the bit I think the the peak
for me though Scott was when Aris was
taunting you with tweets and pictures
yep that was
funny Eris pulled out a picture of like
a dog like and it was like this is Scott
what I do
what have I started yeah oh boy so but
no Honestly though guys if all of you
here you can vote for all of us you
don't have to go pick who you want you
can vote for everybody and then just go
downvote all the non-com I got on there
yeah you know it was before the before
everyone started promoting it like crazy
uh the list was actually pretty solid I
think I was like I like all these
channels good job everybody and then as
soon as everyone started promoting it a
whole bunch of other channels started up
being in the top 10 that I'm like but
these other channels who aren't in the
top 10 should also be in there and I
don't know these other guys in here like
you know what a great example is I like
emergency awesome I watch his stuff but
he's not a comic book Channel and
somehow he's like number six now I I
love that example because I think the
number one comment under his because you
can leave comments with your votes the
number one comment that I saw under his
thing was just like emergency awesome
and some guy just wrote no I saw that I
saw that I was like Oh I thought that
was so funny that's amazing yeah oh well
for the record I am going to say this
you you guys are really mean on there
cuz like me and Rob are going through it
and like I got people on mine that are
like one guy's like I have no idea what
he like what what I don't see what
people like about him another gu like he
needs to shut up or something like that
I'm like what you mean to me like like
some another my favorite comic though I
was like do you the one for you rob you
want to say it the 1990s one because
that was hilarious oh um he knows it we
were joking about it oh some guy some
guy left a comment I'm trying to
remember off top of my head to
paraphrase some guy was like like this
guy talks about old stories like he
stopped reading comics after 1995 or
something like that and I was like
what Scott Scott did mention though he's
got no hate on his side so I think
everyone I haven't checked in a couple
days but I I as s the last time I
checked I had no hate but I did notice
I'm very like I guess nerd sync is very
polarizing because if you look at the
thumbs up and thumbs Downs they're about
even I'm looking at that now I didn't
even think of that yeah so I guess
people just either really hate us or
maybe they think or maybe they think
that thumbs Downs will vote us down
further and they're trying to get their
favorite channels up higher that's what
I think it is I think there are a few
ghost accounts on there a God
okay okay I'm not gonna lie when you
first made your video the first thing I
did was wait watch Mojo doesn't check
the accounts I can make like six and
because when you first made your video
you Bas Me by
six I want to make six accounts are you
saying are you saying that you were
manipulating the voting process well I
was until the third manipulating the
sacred and time honor tradition of the
watch
Mojo here was the funny part because I
made like three of them and I'm like oh
my God that like I I'll just keep myself
like I won't make a video I'll just do
it this way and then like three into it
watch Mojo's like you cannot make any
more
accounts really like there goes that
plan yeah man you're trying to like
trying to gain the system man yeah well
I wasn't even going to game it it's just
he was only six ahead of me and I'm like
well I'm at least going to get even
again like like okay so here was a funny
thing like I was I'm going through the
comments and these are the a lot of
these are the same comment I think
people have stopped commenting at this
point but people like like nine times
out of 10 people are like this guy has
the best voice
ever I noticed that yeah people were
just like posting that everywhere they
were like this guy's got like a buttery
smooth voice and I'm like yes and okay
okay fine you guys want the secret on
how to get my voice all right I promise
you you don't want to know the secret
the secret on how to get my voice is a
smoke cigarettes for 15 years all right
a terrible suggestion do not a horrible
don't do that like I smok for 10 years
to get my voice and that's how I can
talk like this welcome to the complete
story for how Rob got his super secret
sexy voice Rob's voice explain but don't
don't do what we did you know don't do
that that's a terrible idea I will say
though that some of the comments at
least on my thing were super super nice
like uh a lot of people saying like you
know I I kind of take a lot of
inspiration from other YouTubers and so
a lot of people saying things like this
is like the game theory of comic books
I'm like oh my gosh thank you so much
that's
amazing here it is I'm sorry go ahead oh
no I was just yeah you know that's
interesting you should find that
yeah all right so so here's here's that
comment I was trying to find it all
right this guy says this guy blows he
thinks he knows hold on hold on hold on
hold on see like I can't help but laugh
at these comments hold on okay okay so
this guy says this guy blows he thinks
he knows everything thing but all his
videos are simply about 90s events like
he stopped buying comic books in 1995
plus it's not fun simply to hear
something explained commentary is
supposed to be funny I see I had to I
had to add stuff in there because this
guy doesn't know how to doesn't know how
to
grammar but uh commentary is supposed to
be funny and interesting not just a
boring lecture like that guy that guy
thinks I blow
well the mosted comment on my side and
it's at the top still this guy sucks I
can't stand him up voted 34 times
these are all quotes we need to put on
our channels like but right
beneath right beneath that is Comic
storan is great he's not the type of
YouTuber which only releases a video
once a week he releases them at a high
rate and has a perfect amount of content
for the length of his videos he's also
very fun to watch comic story in all the
way down voted 14 times by comic story
yeah yeah I mean I guess all these
naysayers man they they sure showed us I
guess we better just
quit just stop oh my God on internet has
an opinion they don't like me well I
guess that's just the end of that yeah I
guess do even bro the
comments so yeah um I think I think it's
I mean it's fun you guys can go vote for
all of us you can I know Rob made a
video saying that so did Scott and I got
all selfish
but but yeah you guys can go up vote
everybody and I think that's it we're
we're pretty much hitting our hour and a
half time limit here Rob so I'll go do
it real quick uh real fast guys check
out Scott if you don't know who nerd SN
is he's he's pretty hefty into the the
entire uh comic book Community he chats
with all of us you can see him on
Twitter all the time he does do great
content I mean if you're looking for a
comic book channel that doesn't just
rehash origins in in our style you know
Rob tells origins in his style I tell
him in my style s tells you the origins
you know in a funny manner because he
hates on everything new after the year
2000 but it's hilarious I love it but
Scott tells you stuff in a interesting
manner he tells stuff like why would you
move to Gotham you know and he tells you
stuff like uh what does Dr Doom's face
look like what does Dr Doom's face look
like and my personal favorite and I saw
it in a while and I I wanted to ask you
but we didn't have time today I don't
know why you did this one I haven't
watched it yet but is Thor a Nazi that's
like one of your
first there's a fun story behind that
one I guess we won't get into oh well
have we'll next time you're on here
thing YouTuber registration act
enabled
so so guys go check out Scott's Channel
if you aren't aware of it we we all we
are all huge fans of him we all check
chat with him we're all friends here in
the comic book YouTuber Avengers front
you know Scott Scott is our Spider-Man
he's he's our guy that shows up when it
gets really bad and then just kind of
mind my own business every all the rest
of the time right yeah yeah he's he's
he's off in his own corner and he swings
in when the whole world's going down and
we need Spider-Man for some weird reason
soly go check him out um and then as
usual why don't we go through what we're
all going to do for the week um I guess
since I'm talking I'll go first but I'm
putting out thorn of atanas we're
putting out the story of blackand um
we're also putting out the story of Miss
Marvel put out way too many videos and
we're also putting out
Neymar oh boy uh why don't you go next
out because on my screen you're next on
the list sure uh since I am next on the
list uh tomorrow uh today we premiered
uh the third episode of hack and splash
page starring the real
zubs uh which she uh she did a an
episode about the the boom Studios book
Eternal um tomorrow is off the rack
where we talk about Batman and Robin the
new the new issue of Batman Robin uh the
uh the new book Gotham Academy little
bit and um I can't remember what the
other book was oh Wolverine's number
three and then on back issues on
Thursday we talk about uh a Spider-Man
book that is particularly controversial
it's not the most controversial but it
is written by
sosinski and has something to do with
the uh the spiderverse event huh cool I
don't have to give it all away you
know uh Rob you're next on my screen
Scott well I thought I thought Scott you
can go ahead that's fine oh yeah sure um
so just this week I think yesterday we
had a podcast with uh you Benny on it so
people can check that out tomorrow there
you go yeah you it's actually a really
fun episode I got a lot of comments
about people saying that it was one of
their favorite episodes so there you go
um that's the nerdsync podcast you can
search for that on iTunes or uh wherever
else unlike Rob Scott puts his on iTunes
I put it on iTunes man I put it on
Soundcloud I put it everywhere if you
want to listen to it um and then
tomorrow I have comic Mis tomorrow's
Wednesday right my days run together all
right I have an episode of comic
misconceptions which is kind of like the
main comic book show that we do on the
nerd sync and I'm going to be tackling
the uh the the the question the big
question on everyone's mind why is Lex
Luthor bald and so I'm gonna be talking
a lot about both the incomics reasons
and the outof comics reasons why the
writers and creators decided to make him
bald so really interesting stuff I think
and then uh we premiered a new series
last week that's just kind of it's
called tie-ins and they're just like
mini episodes that kind of tie into the
comic misconception so this one is a
little bit bizarre it's just something
that really interests me and I really
hope other people like it but I'm
basically dissecting like the atmology
of the name Lex Luther and trying to
figure out like why why is he called
that what does it mean like what does it
represent with his character and like
what he does in his place in the comics
like what does the name Alexander Luther
actually mean and seeing if that does
anything I just like to learn things I
guess I like looking up words and
Origins I just my my the pallet of
things I like to learn about is like the
broadest thing ever so that's what we're
doing this week cool awesome oh I do
want to State one thing your Lex Luther
episode would have been so much better
if you shaved your head you know I
really thought about that I really I did
trim it up today but I didn't yeah I
didn't shave that was definitely on my
mind though Rob yeah um anyway um Rob go
Rob Rob you're up
Rob I have I don't think I I don't think
I've properly interrupted you all
episode I needed to do at least once
actually you haven't and yeah I think
this guy blows that was NE this guy
blows all he does is interrupt
Rob that's that's the so long story
short Scott uh I have a tendency to be a
as as they've said in the comments in
watch Mojo aggressive indiscretions and
I interrupt Rob too much so hilarious
like people people post that like you go
through there and they're like this like
byy just interrupts people too much like
somebody somebody sat there they were
watching that like you know what like
this needs to be said like this needs to
be said I create account and go there
and tell them I thought you were gonna
say people sat through it and counted
the amount of times that he I think they
did that
one like with with the time stamps and
everything like at three minutes four
seconds for and the best part is like
every time they leave those comments I
normally launch the next episode with
guys I'm still here so guess what if you
don't like it don't
watch I Didn't hack your account and
resubscribe anyway uh spiderverse 2
spiderverse part two comes out tomorrow
hopefully we'll have that finished by
the end of the week and then after that
after okay after
that all com
imagine after that my my lovely my
lovely subscribers after that we'll get
back into character discussions so yeah
done and done nice oh my
God by the way I'm gonna go ahead and
say it Rob's three minute challenge idea
was amazing and I loved it oh okay okay
okay guys look here just just we're just
we're clear on the three minute
challenge that was an experiment the
three-minute challenge is not going to
replace character discussions in fact I
might add it on two character
discussions I might do a through like
I'm going to do a full discussion on the
vision I might do a full discussion on
squirrel girl I don't know why the hell
I would but I might do a full discussion
on Squirrel Girl and then do a
three-minute challenge although the
three-minute challenge will be the same
as the discussion on squirrel girl but
nonetheless because you're continuity
short and she's not that important
although Al she's unbeatable so you know
there probably squeeze an extra minute
out of that the three-minute challenge
is not designed to be a replacement for
full character discussions it's just to
see if I can do it in three minutes
that's all it is it's just an experiment
to see if
challenge that's why it says it's not
three minute explanation it's not you
know three minute expert it's the three
minute
challenge you know anyway so yeah but
there's a request for a mad Jim Jasper's
episode but I think we should end it on
that before you give him an answer I'm
not gonna go
in I'm not gonna go into MIM Jasper do
it in three minutes
anyway I will I will answer this
question though somebody asked a
question who will win Franklin Richards
or MIM Jaspers Franklin Richards wins
we'll explain that why in the next
podcast well I can touch you that one
anyway uh all right guys thanks for
joining us today uh it's the as usual we
always appreciate you guys joining us
we'll be here next Tuesday at the same
time same weekly Pool Time same weekly
pool Channel and for those of you guys
wondering about the website it is still
on track for February 1st we are going
to get it up and running and we'll see
what happens from there so thank you
everybody uh everyone do a send off sure
yeah
bye see you yeah with that being said
we're gonna bring this podcast to an
end I'll catch you guys later peace